from breathtaking action sequences that
are arguably better than those in the
first film to the continued use of tired
and harmful tropes here are the six best
and six worst things about Avatar the
way of water ranked James Cameron is
well known for being at the Forefront of
advancing the tech behind visual effects
in film especially with regards to using
computer-generated images or CGI while
there have been computer-generated
visual effects in films going as far
back as 1973 with the original Westworld
Cameron is famous for continuing to push
the technology further with each
successive project for instance in
1989's the abyss Cameron used at the
time state-of-the-art CGI to create the
now famous water tentacle with digitally
mapped 3D faces of the actors he then
created the first partially CG main
character in Robert Patrick's liquid
metal T-1000 form and Terminator 2
Judgment Day and later pushed the tech
once more in 2009's Avatar it must be
said that the CGI and Avatar the way of
water is indeed pretty impressive while
the visuals in the original Avatar were
cutting edge at the time they like a lot
of CGI effects in films before it have
shown their age a bit however the
advancement in visual effects technology
between the first Avatar and the way of
water is palpable it's especially
noticeable when the film focuses on the
navi facial features or anything
involving the physics of water not only
that but there are many effects heavy
scenes in the film which coupled with
filming in a higher frame rate makes it
feel like you're literally on Pandora
despite the previously mentioned moments
of special effects greatness there are
also some VFX shots that were obviously
given more care than others despite a
long gestating 13-year gap between
Avatar the way of water and the original
Avatar there's still not an infinite
amount of time to design plan and render
each shot especially for film that is
mostly CG animated this is all
exacerbated by the fact that director
James Cameron insisted on creating new
tech specifically for the film but also
meant that research and development for
the new tech inevitably cut into
rendering times for the individual shots
this is not to mention the lack of
unionization in the VFX industry that
leads to artist burnout fast turnarounds
and Outsourcing some shots to VFX houses
offering the lowest bid rather than the
best quality this is admittedly an
industry-wide issue and not just
relegated to Avatar the way of water but
still it needs to be mentioned
James Cameron has had a prolific career
as an A-list director and one of the
main things he's known for is his
amazing action scenes even his epic
period Drama Titanic which focused most
of its three-hour plus run time on a
budding romance still had an intense
pulse-pounding 40-minute climax
featuring some of the best action
sequences in cinema history to this day
[Applause]
Avatar the way of water is no exception
there are so many great actions set
pieces in the film that rival and
arguably surpass the 2009 original this
includes an exciting futuristic train
Heist near the beginning of the film a
scene where the evil RDA Corporation
chases down a herd of the sentient
whale-like tolkun and the climax on the
ocean where Jake Sully leads his family
into the marine-based mechaina tribe
against a newly resurrected Colonel
quarrich and his gang the finale in
particular is a really breathtaking
sequence and showcases why Cameron is
the top of the game in terms of action
genre Cinema the blocking is clear and
precise the spatial orientation is
always legible and there's no overuse of
either shaky cam or the overdone Zack
snyder-esque slowdown ramp up technique
James Cameron is no stranger to having
long run times for his films 1997's
Titanic for instance was 3 hours and 14
minutes even the original Avatar wasn't
anemic either with a 2 hour and 41
minute run time while Avatar the way of
water may not be the longest film in
Cameron's career clocking in at 3 hours
and 12 minutes it's still one of the
longest mainstream Hollywood films in
recent memory with only Avengers end
game coming close at a minute over three
hours this is not to say that long run
times are inherently bad far from it
this year's Blockbuster tollywood period
action adventure film rrr ran for three
hours and seven minutes and is one of
2022's most financially and critically
successful films worldwide however rrr
along with most of the three hour plus
epics from decades past at least had
intermissions which is not the case for
modern theatrical films to be fair James
Cameron has suggested seeing the movie
multiple times if going to the bathroom
is a problem though that seems to be a
solution that's more than a bit
self-serving
whatever critics might say about the
quality or lack thereof concerning the
visual effects in avatar The Way of
water the art Direction on the film is
at least consistently phenomenal
regardless honestly the style of the
film truly evokes the aesthetic of the
old Lisa Frank Trapper Keepers from the
80s and 90s and that's a good thing the
film is just so full of vibrant
saturated and bright colors that nothing
else that has come out in cinemas for
the last few years looks quite like it
the production design is frankly Next
Level and stands Head and Shoulders
above a lot of other big budget sci-fi
films of the same caliber there's almost
no comparison to the amount of detail
that James Cameron has put into building
every single nook and cranny of Pandora
this includes the idyllic Coastal Mech
hyena Villages and the militaristic RDA
corporate facility that contrasts
greatly with the naturalistic Pandora
and Landscape surrounding it the various
cool and exotic alien creatures in the
sequel are often a sight to behold as
well in particular the sentient
whale-like tokuns or the skim Wing
creatures that the mechaina navi tribe
ride which are similar to the flying
ikran from the first film
one of the biggest issues with the first
avatar was the story's inherent white
savior issue while pretty
self-explanatory the term white savior
refers to an extremely outdated and
arguably white supremacist narrative
Trope in fiction where a white person
joins a group of marginalized people and
instantly becomes the best of them this
fits the story of the original Avatar to
a t as a white man named Jake Sully
becomes part of the indigenous coded
alien Navi tribe on Pandora and ends up
not only being the best of them but also
literally becoming their leader to be
clear this is not to say that Avatar is
intentionally hateful or anything like
that but it's not great when the film
nonetheless reinforces harmful narrative
tropes like the white Savior and the
noble savage which fit the depiction of
the navi as well unfortunately Avatar
the way of water does little to
alleviate these problems and in fact
compounds them Jake ends up leading an
attack on the humans with not just his
own family but also commanding the
literal King of the mechananavi tribe as
well his negligent actions also lead
directly to the devastation of many
metcaina villages which never amounts to
much in in the way of consequences for
him
James Cameron is known for making some
of the best sequels of all time whether
it's following up Ridley Scott's classic
sci-fi horror film Alien with one of the
best Sci-Fi Action flicks ever in aliens
or continuing his own Terminator tale
with Terminator 2 Judgment Day that
somehow made Arnold Schwarzenegger's
deadly Terminator lovable enough to cry
over
because you told me to
in both cases Cameron was able to find a
way to turn those Original Stories on
their heads but also made sure that what
made those films work in the first place
remained intact such as keeping the
Xenomorphs scary or letting both
Terminator films be explosive bloody and
thrilling the same goes for Avatar the
way of water Cameron keeps what worked
in the first film The amazingly rendered
environments the anti-corporate message
and the Deep spiritual mythology and
adds some new much-appreciated wrinkles
one of the most narratively satisfying
additions to the sequel is the inclusion
of the Met kaina Clan an aquatic-based
Navi tribe living on the beaches near
Pandora's oceans the initial tension
between Jake and the mech hyena as well
as the sense that the navi tribes have
long-standing prejudices against each
other makes the world feel much more
real and nuanced it also raises the
stakes by making fighting off the humans
that much harder which also reflects
indigenous struggles against
colonization in our world
Stephen Lang is a great actor in many of
his roles he's able to effortlessly
exude extreme intensity and Menace
including his performance as Avatar main
antagonist Colonel Miles courage
you crossed the line
in that first film quartz thematically
represents the military arm of
capitalistic imperialism as the massive
Corporation RDA contracts the Earth
military to Aid in Pandora's
colonization which is based around
wiping out or enslaving the native Navi
population to ease efforts in exploiting
the planet's special resource on
obtainium Lang does a great job in the
role he's just the right mix of arrogant
strong-willed and scary to be a worthy
adversary for the heroes however he's
also a bit one-dimensional it's fine for
the story that Avatar tells which is
more about Jake Sully discovering and
learning to love Pandora and the navi it
makes sense that more screen time and
narrative real estate is given to that
plotline rather than developing quarrich
as a character but unlike fun or
interesting villains like Loki or
Hannibal Lecter quarrich is just not
compelling enough to bring back as
written he was always just a
stereotypical military guy to be fair
Cameron does attempt to add layers to
quarrich and Avatar the way of water
particularly his relationship to his
left behind Sons fighter still though
even that's hacky and cliche in its own
way hearkening back to the fact that so
many villains have Daddy Issues already
like any good spectacle-filled action
epic there are a lot of Applause worthy
moments sprinkled throughout Avatar the
way of water however none are as
crowd-pleasing as the scene where a
banished tolkun a massive sentient
whale-like creature that is a vital part
of mechanic culture jumps out of the
ocean to completely decimate an
rda-funded tolkun hunting vessel
honestly the banished tolkun character
who is befriended by Jake Sully's
youngest son Loach is a highlight of the
film in general the bond that forms
between loac and the banished tolkun has
all the Hallmarks of a classic a boy and
his ex-story but done extremely well the
subplot takes its time to tease out the
banished to tolkun's tragic backstory as
loac initially discovers the tolkun
covered in injuries with remnants of
Earth Tech embedded in its hide the
film's extended run time also allows for
the tolkun and lowax deep friendship to
grow naturally and makes the tolkun's
Redemption in helping the navi fight the
humans that much more satisfying
as an actress Sigourney Weaver is a
nerdy fan favorite starring in many
classic Sci-fi genre Staples over the
years such as Galaxy Quest all but one
Ghostbusters film and of course as Ellen
Ripley in the alien franchise Weaver
returned to Star and Cameron's Avatar in
2009 where she plays Dr Grace Augustine
a highly regarded xenobotanist on
Pandora who is also the head of the
Avatar program that puts human Minds
into knobby bodies Dr Augustine is also
sympathetic to Pandora and the navi
unlike a lot of her human colleagues you
need to listen to what she says
try to see the forest
through her eyes unfortunately she dies
before the end of the first film after
an attempt to resurrect her at the Tree
of Souls fails surprisingly like Lang
Weaver returns an avatar the way of
water however unlike Lang Weaver returns
as a new Navi character named Kiri the
adopted teen daughter of Jake Sully and
natiri unfortunately despite her best
efforts Weaver playing a teenager is
simply too distracting to work Weaver of
course is an amazing actress but it's
still not enough to hide the fact that
she is starring alongside actual young
adults as her siblings though her Navi
form looks like a young blue Sigourney
Weaver The Voice doesn't and it comes
off as unsettling more than anything
else
whatever James Cameron's Faults Are as a
Storyteller his lack of subtlety is not
one of them say what you will about
Avatar but the themes of anti-capitalism
are very clear and well defined in that
film the audience unambiguously
Witnesses the violent devastating
effects that careless untethered
capitalistic greed has on the beauty and
balance of Nature and how its Lust For
infinite growth also leads to the
genocide of entire cultures like the
navi or indigenous tribes in real life
this anti-capitalist messaging is
thankfully maintained in avatar The Way
of water in fact that message is
expanded upon in the new film we find
out that there's a whole operation run
by the RDA where they round up and
Slaughter entire families of tolkun
Simply to extract a single vial of brain
fluid meanwhile the corpse of the
whale-sized creature is left to rot in
the ocean this is reminiscent of the
wasteful and inhumane wailing practices
on Earth today
one of the best characters from the
original Avatar film was the proud and
strong Navi warrior natiri with Zoe
Saldana of Guardians of the Galaxy Fame
doing the vocal and motion capture
performance for her in fact natiri's
Beauty strength and bravery are the main
reasons that Sam worthington's Jake
Sully switches sides deciding to protect
the navi from the invading human Army
she is Jake's and the audience's guide
to the wondrous world of Pandora and her
and Jake's love story is the emotional
Crux of the entire first film
woman must don't
[Music]
she already has
unfortunately in avatar The Way of water
Saldana's natiri is pretty much
sidelined for most of the film's arduous
run time she mostly plays the cliche
role of the concerned wife and mother
usually in the background fretting while
Jake and her children get to do all the
narrative heavy lifting there are even
some very uncomfortable moments when
Jake forcefully shuts her up after she
brings up valid complaints yikes to be
fair the sequel shifts the focus away
from Jake as well since the story is a
generational one about their kids
instead of them but Jake still gets a
lot more to do in the way of water while
in the first one natiri and Jake's
importance to the overall narrative was
much more equal also while it's true
that natiri gets to be an awesome
Warrior during the climax it's also kind
of a too little too late situation at
that point
foreign